[Music]
when we were little girls we wished we
could live happy ever after like these
beautiful Disney Princesses and now it
is time for little boys to dream too
many artists reimagine our favorite
female characters as men and we couldn't
help but think of the different stories
they would live wait until you see the
genderbent Pocahontas you'll want to be
his Jenna Smith if this is your first
time visiting our channel don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up here are 10 Disney
Princesses reimagined as opposite
genders Elsa we know Elsa as the
beautiful ice queen who trapped her
Kingdom into a perpetual winter she
decided to let it go and live alone in
her ice castle until her sister Anna
came back to deliver her with the power
of love she wasn't a queen like any
other but what would she look like if
she were men just take a look at this
picture from let there be doodles
this artist imagined Elsa and her sister
Anna's men we will name them Ellis and
Anna tall they look really similar to
the original characters instead of her
long blond hair and blue dress Ellis has
shorter hair and wears a sparkly blue
shirt Anna tall's hair was cut too but
he kept his blonde streak his freckles
and his bubbly personality we bet these
brothers love each other just as much as
Elsa and Anna did even though they may
be a little too shy to show it suck kami
chen is another artist who reimagined
Elsa as a powerful Ice King but this
time he looks a bit malicious with his
arched eyebrows suspicious eyes and
powerful hens we hope that he wants to
use his magic powers for everyone's good
just like the Queen did we want to make
sure Ellis is on our side or this story
could become quite scary Arielle here is
our favorite Little Mermaid after saving
a man and falling in love with him
Arielle knew that she had to do
everything she could to spend the rest
of her life with this Prince but what
would happen if the spell failed and
Ariel was turned into a boy instead of a
human take a look at this picture from
leatherby doodles we call him Adrian and
we bet that he would be fascinated by
life on land just like Ariel was he
seems just as curious and adventurous as
our favorite character was but that's
not all another artist named tsuchimi
Chen imagined Ariel as a man to this
time the Merman doesn't wear clams on
his chest but as an
list around his neck and look at what he
has on his arm his most precious
discovery do you think he still brushes
his hair with the fork or maybe he uses
the utensil for his beer to when he
grows one his best friend flounder also
turned into a girl and she looks really
beautiful with that little flower on her
head but the best thing to look at is
this sea creature who looks even better
as a men he won't have to become a human
to meet the love of his life when they
see him all the girls would want to
become a mermaid and join him under the
sea Cinderella after her father had
passed away the poor Cinderella was
forced to work as a serpent for her
stepmother and stepsisters but when she
went to the ball the Prince immediately
fell in love with her after that night
he did everything he can to find that
beautiful woman and marry her but what
if a man was the hero of this
rags-to-riches story this is what
animation student maoli imagined he
would look like and we would name him
cinderfella don't think only women can
clean the house this man is ready for
this challenge - even if you would
rather be at the ball fortunately his
fairy godfather heard about this wish
and gave him a beautiful sparkly suit so
he could meet the princess charming
little did he know she would quickly
fall in love with him at the ball who
can resist a man who knows that he has
to do his part when it comes to cleaning
the house and we have to admit that
cinderfella looks good too but another
artist imagined another ending to this
story and we have to say it is really
funny look at what an artist from the D
continuum thought about this man's feet
would be so big that they wouldn't fit
in the glass shoe anymore we wish
princess charming recognized him anyways
so they could live happily ever after
just like Cinderella did Tiana what we
love the most about Tiana was that she
was one of the only princesses with a
real job this girl knew the importance
of working hard but things didn't go as
expected when she kissed a frog and
became a frog - but what would happen if
this girl was turned into a man instead
look at what let there be doodles
imagined we will call this new character
theory and even though he woke up this
morning as the opposite gender he would
go to work anyway just like Tiana this
man knows that you need to be reliable
and always do your best
nothing will stop him from opening the
finest restaurant in New Orleans tumblr
artist tech notic imagine the princess
is a male way
or two and we have to say that he looks
really good he would certainly deserve a
good tip with this beautiful smile and
actually teary would earn more money
simply because he is a man that is so
unfair Tianna was already really
hardworking and ambitious all she needs
was a good opportunity to make her
dreams come true do you think your life
would be different it turned into a man
or woman tell us what you think in the
comments down below
snow white she was the first Disney
princess since the movie premiered in
1937 and we never stopped loving her her
stepmother was jealous of her beauty and
did everything she could to get rid of
Snow White
the princess escaped and lived with
Seven Dwarves until the day she took a
bite of a poisonous Apple and had to be
saved by the prince
but what would snow white look like as
men as we can see in this artwork from
let there be doodles he would be really
handsome - we understand why his
stepfathers jealous this young man is a
heartbreaker
and it seems like animals are still in
love with him but an artist on the D
continuum thought about a different
story
he simply switched the roles of Snow
White in the Prince the man becomes a
woman and the girl becomes a boy the
beautiful Snow White is now the one
trying to seduce the Prince and it
should be easy for her she is the
fairest of them all after all Prince
Charming would take the place of the
young woman who has to escape from her
stepmother we can already imagine him
singing one day my princess will come
women can make the first move - it is
time for Disney Princess to save her
prince Belle this young woman wasn't
interested in meeting a prince but she
had no choice when the beast trapped her
father behind bars she offered to take
his place and the strange creature
accepted she never knew that the best
way to escape would be to make him fall
in love with her and become a better man
and he became so charming that she
decided to stay anyway but what would it
be like if fell was actually a man we
will make him bow and as you can see
from the work of an artist on Instagram
his name suits him very well his look is
much simpler without the makeup and the
bow in his hair but isn't this
difference what makes him look so good
tsukimi Chen also reimagined the Beauty
and the Beast as the opposite gender and
the results are amazing
the Beast is doing her best to impress
Bo and it shows her inner beauty is
shining through standing next to her is
the young man who still loves reading
books as you can see in this picture but
what he seems
be even more passionate about is the
beast just look at these two looking at
each other in the eyes we know that they
are meant to be together all I need is a
declaration of love and the Beast will
turn into a beautiful princess or they
could just learn to like themselves as
they are a woman doesn't need to shave
Aurora the witch Maleficent cursed the
princess so her life would end on her
16th birthday but thanks to another
fairy she only fell into a deep sleep
for many days and nights but her dreams
finally became a reality when Prince
Philip saved her with a kiss of love
this is a fairy tale everyone would like
to live sleeping as much as you want and
waking up to a happy ending so let's
give men the chance to be a part of this
story - by turning Aurora into a man we
will call him Aron and as you can see
from a picture from letter V doodles he
looks a lot like the princess they could
be brother and sister but there is one
thing we were wondering about would he
be wearing a pink suit or a blue suit
this choice is so difficult to make so
let's take a break and walk in the
forest to think about this here's what
deviantART artist Edgar I imagined Aron
would look like as you can see animals
love this man just as much as they love
the Sleeping Beauty with his blond hair
blue eyes and beautiful smile he looks
just like mr. right if only we could be
the princess waking him up with a kiss
but beware
Maleficent might try to stop you
Rapunzel after spending years alone in a
tower the girl with the longest hair
found a thief hiding in her room
Rapunzel had never seen a man before in
her life so she didn't know what to do
he gave her the chance to escape and
live an adventure she always dreamed of
Flynn Rider might have tried to steal
her crown but she stole her heart
instead and what if this story happened
to be a man we will call him Rapunzel
let there be doodles created a picture
of Rapunzel as a man and we have to say
that these two look really similar with
the long hair it's difficult to
differentiate a woman from a young men
but as you can see Rapunzel has more
brown streaks on his head he tried to
cut his hair to look like all the other
boys his overprotective father wouldn't
like to hear about this Esther Shannon's
another artist who imagined Rapunzel and
Flynn as opposite genders and as you can
see from the first time they met each
other they were already feeling
something robando tied up the thief to a
chair and he looks like
never wants to let her go the thief
couldn't think of a better place to be
trapped aren't they your favorite couple
Jasmine when Aladdin free to genie from
a lamp all his wishes were granted the
thief wanted to become a prince so he
could be near Jasmine but what he didn't
know was that he was not the only one
wanting to marry the princess but at the
end his personality and courage brought
enough magic to save the girl and make
her fall in love with him and once again
we want to see what this princess would
look like if she was a man we will call
him Jasper let there be doodles imagined
him with shorter hair and a headband of
another color but what makes the biggest
difference is that he has no makeup in
no earrings this tumblr artist even
created a picture of the prince dressed
for Jafar by the looks of it this scene
would be much more interesting with the
men don't you think bull wait we have
even more artwork to show you ex Rima is
another artist on deviantART who wanted
to see what jasmine and Aladdin would
look like as opposite genders and she
made our dream come true with this
picture they did not only swap their
wardrobe they also swapped the
personality as well wouldn't it be nice
to see a guy fall for the bad girl just
for once
Pocahontas the Native American was
surprised to see Europeans coming to her
village but she didn't let the fear of
the unknown stop her
Pocahontas quickly fell in love with
John Smith and told him about the beauty
of nature but you know what is even more
beautiful Pocahontas as a men as you can
see from this picture created by let
there be doodles his hair and body paint
were adapted to make him look more
masculine and instead of a necklace from
his mother this young man probably got
this necklace from his father but this
artist is not the only one who
reimagined the Native American just take
a look at this creation from sashimi
Chan finding a new world was not the
most important discovery at the time but
meeting this man would probably be
something that you remember forever
Pocahontas his true love is still nature
but this time he is a warrior ready to
fight to protect it with the body paint
on his hands and on his face this man
looks even more powerful and when we see
the determination on his face we can't
help but be inspired to follow him on an
adventure this man is so handsome we
wish we could be his Jenny Smith would
you be one of the girls fighting to win
his heart and that's it for 10 Disney
Princesses Rhea
imagined as opposite genders if you
could see one of these movies based on
these new characters which one would you
like to see don't forget to tell us in
the comments down below and for more
stories like this don't forget to
subscribe to the things and watch 10
Disney Princesses reimagined by amazing
artists thanks for watching
[Music]